scp-096 versus scp-082  the weeping screaming shy guy versus the  intensely talkative ferdinand the  cannibal who would take home the title  belt in a fight to the death both  creatures are durable and violent with  no qualms about murdering and  potentially devouring any human beings  that get on their bad side ferdinand is  also resistant to most forms of  conventional weapons from gunfire to  swords he can also bite off a human head  in one bite and go toe-to-toe with  scp-682 however we'd personally give  this one to the shy guy ferdinand  essentially functions as a larger more  dangerous human and 096 can tear through  literal tanks like butter the victory  goes to  scp-096 on this one